We all know that mistakes happen.
But when hundreds of millions of dollars are
on the line, you would think that people would
pay even closer attention to detail.
In the world of movie-making, the opposite
is true.
The bigger the movie… the bigger the mistakes.
They’re not all bad, and plenty of them
can be downright hilarious.
Either way, fans won’t want to miss a single
one of them.
Here are Screen Rant’s 10 Biggest Editing
Mistakes in Movies.
Mad Max: Fury Road
With the amount of practical effects and stunt
work in George Miller’s insane story of
car carnage, a few visible safety harnesses
or wires wouldn’t be surprising.
After all, the actors can’t really take
the risks of their characters.
But one major mistake has nothing to do with
the ambitious action of the movie.
When Immortan Joe and his War Boys are blocked
in a desert canyon, an aerial shot shows his
entire war party stuck in one spot.
But pay close attention to the side of the
screen, and you’ll catch the entire crew
taking in the sights, clearly assuming the
pounding war drums will keep the audience
distracted.
The Avengers: Age of Ultron
In the second team-up of Marvel’s biggest
heroes, a pair of superpowered siblings give
the heroes a run for their money.
But when Quicksilver and Scarlet Witch join
the good side before the movie’s final battle,
they put their talents to good use, helping
evacuate an entire city.
The speedster tries to alert the police, but
finds out that gunfire is all that will get
their attention.
Bursting in and out got a laugh from audiences,
but his speed isn’t a special effect.
The actors did their best to hold still, but
their jerking movements show the footage was
simply sped up and slowed down.
Once you spot it, you might wonder how you
ever missed it.
Jurassic World
In the world of film, nothing says “death”
like watching a heart rate monitor flatline.
In Jurassic World, a team of dinosaur containment
soldiers prove that point when tackling the
movie’s biggest, deadliest creature, and
dropping one after the other.
But the effects team clearly assumed people
wouldn’t be looking too closely at the hearts
still beating – not only do the heart rates
stay steady as the squad is being slaughtered,
but the EKG patterns themselves are flawed.
They made sure to keep every heart from beating
at the same time, but in a dozen soldiers,
even TWO having identical patterns is impossible,
let alone every one of them.
The movie isn’t the first to cheat with
an EKG, and it definitely won’t be the last.
Guardians of the Galaxy
Marvel’s team of space outlaws are some
truly colorful characters.
None is stranger than Drax, the green-skinned,
tattooed alien who audiences are told can’t
understand metaphors.
The idea of Drax being completely literal
is played for a few jokes, but the character
explicitly drops the idea for one line.
Before the attack on Ronan’s forces, Drax
lets a fellow warrior know what he thinks
of their fighting abilities.
That’s not just a metaphor, but a particularly
vivid one, at that.
American Sniper
Nobody would have guessed that Clint Eastwood’s
story of a real American soldier would bring
in over a half a billion dollars at the global
box office.
If they did, then the filmmakers may have
spent a bit more money bringing the main character’s
child to life.
When two real-life babies were unable to shoot
their scene, the crew apparently decided a
doll was good enough.
Some CG was used to animate the baby’s hand,
but once star Bradley Cooper took it in his
arms, the act completely dropped.
Instead of changing the scene or cutting around
it, one of the fakest babies to every appear
in a blockbuster movie took center stage.
Frozen
If there’s one thing you can say about Disney
and Pixar, it’s that they’ve truly risen
to their very own level of animated moviemaking.
It’s that fact that makes any mistake that
slips into a modern Disney movie even more
shocking – and Frozen was no exception.
When the movie’s villain has been dealt
with, and every cast member is getting their
happy ending, Anna and Kristoff share their
first kiss, as he literally sweeps her off
her feet.
With the story wrapping up, the animators
either missed the fact that Kristoff’s thumb
glitches into Anna’s body, or decided it
was too small to ever be noticed.
They may be right, but it’s moments like
these that remind movie fans that even the
experts aren’t always perfect.
Captain America: The Winter Soldier
Steve Rogers took it hard when he learned
that his former best friend had been turned
into the brainwashed assassin known as The
Winter Soldier.
But Cap should probably have been tipped off
when the story of Bucky’s disappearance
– and even his life – didn’t quite add
up.
According to the museum display for the fallen
soldier, Bucky was “born in 1916” – but
the same plaque also claims he was born in
1917 at the bottom, and died in 1944, when
he fell to his presumed death in The First
Avenger.
So, he died in 1944 then.
Except that was on the same day that Arnim
Zola was captured, which, according to the
Dr.’s artifical likeness, was another year
later.
It’s hard to even guess where the mistakes
actually started.
Furious 7
It took seven movies for the Fast & Furious
series to answer the question: who is man
enough to bring down Jason Statham?
Vin Diesel and Dwayne Johnson pulled it off,
with the villain being put away in a solitary
cell for years to come.
The good news, though, is he won’t be alone.
When the supercop Hobbs finally locks him
up, audiences are supposed to be looking at
the hero’s grin.
They’re not supposed to notice the cameraman
standing in front of Statham, clearly visible
in the window’s reflection, blocking the
actor’s orange jumpsuit.
Then reflected again, outside of the cell.
Maybe that’s why Statham seemed so angry?
Transformers: Age of Extinction
Audiences may never be able to guess just
how much of what they see on screen was actually
filmed, and how much was added later using
computers.
Luckily, director Michael Bay doesn’t always
make it hard to tell.
In the fourth Transformers movie, an elite
team of Autobot-hunters works alongside the
villain to kill any and all Transformers.
Viewers might wonder why some of the video
screens being monitored by the team leader
are just green squares.
It’s a trick used to capture the screens
on set, with video feeds or monitors to be
added in later.
Apparently, the effects team decided they
only had a few ideas for interesting footage,
and left the rest of the screens blank.
The giant robots might have taken up most
of their time.
X-Men: Days of Future Past
In a movie packed with fan-favorite X-Men,
it wasn’t easy for Quicksilver to stand
out.
But using his super speed to take down a room
full of Pentagon security won over skeptics,
after he’d already shown he was the only
mutant capable of breaking Magneto out of
prison.
Unfortunately, those paying close attention
spotted some strange mistakes.
When Quicksilver actually runs Magneto out
of containment, he moves so fast, the guards
storming the cell are sent flying.
But once the pair make it to the elevator,
the guards are missing from the hallway behind.
And even harder to miss is the black and white
striped paint job that’s replaced the clean
white walls he entered through.
A change in location is obviously to blame,
but there had to have been a subtler solution.
So what do you think of our list?
Did we miss any mistakes, errors or screw-ups
in your favorite movies?
Let us know in our comment section and don't
forget to subscribe to our channel for more
videos like this one.